Before concluding this class on java development, I want to
talk about another process that is very popular these days, and
it's used in many companies, which is called Scrum. Which similar
to XP is another agile development process, and I'm going to
start by discussing what the Scrum actors are. There's three
main kinds of actors. The first one is the product owner,
which means the customer. The product owner is mainly responsible for
the product back log, where the product back log is basically
the list of things that have to be done, the
back log in fact for the project. And that is
analogous to the user stories to be realized in XP,
that we just saw. So what the product owner does is
to clearly express these back log items, and to also
order them by value, so they can be prioritized. The second
actor is the team. The team is responsible for delivering
shippable increments to estimate the
back log items. It's normally self-organized,
consists of four to nine people, and it's what you
would consider normally as the main development team in a
project. And finally we have the Scrum master. The Scrum
master is the person who's responsible for the overall Scrum process,
so he or she has to remove obstacles, facilitate events,
helps communications, and so on. So you you can see
the Scrum master as sort of a manager or the
person who's got oversight, or the supervisor of the Scrum process.